george haas welcome to the show
thank you happy to be here
i'm so excited for this episode
fingers crossed surrender to the divine
flow
i'm very grateful to michael holt for
making the introduction
i love michael yes
the savage and the scene
[Laughter]
he spoke very highly of you when he was
on the program
and we had a great conversation
and we've actually been chatting it up
for an hour
since you arrived and we've been having
a great
back and forth i'm excited to share with
our audience
let's dive in
i was asking you a bit about this on
the couch while we were sitting
you had this long
artistic music photography
film new york
flow and then this shift
came to l.a started sitting with
shinzen young exploring
with dan brown i'm so interested
what was the point of shift
for you towards interest in spirituality
interest in awakening and that was
around 2003
um you know i'm a child of the 60s so it
was the white album by the beatles
[Laughter]
actually that did that uh you know i was
in high school
in the 60s and uh
it was uh hippie times and so
we began then um
i grew up in upper middle class in
chicago
in the chicago area and uh
highly upwardly mobile uh parents my
both of my grandmothers were first
generation irish
you know famine irish
so poor they came and were very
indoctrinated into the idea that
we should be upwardly mobile and so i
had that education
my father was sadistic my mother was
really not that functional
and so the childhood was kind of rough
and what you know
from your own childhood experience
perhaps is that you go along with the
way the house runs until you get to
adolescence
and then when your mind changes just
from the natural growth of
the cognitive capacity you can analyze
for the first time whether the deals
that your parents made with you were
good deals or not
then if you discovered that they
actually were not good deals
and that they were really only serving
the interests of your parents
you turn away from all adults
you turn away from your parents but
because the cognitive capacities of the
adolescent brain are not that well
organized you make a kind of blanket
decision
that all adults are not trustworthy
and then who do you turn to but your
peer group of people who've also made
that decision and then you
uh try and organize the uh your
passage through the this part of you
know the childhood transition into
youth and so there was also
a lot of drug and alcohol use i i was
already
an addict in elementary school
so when i say that the conditions in my
household were rough
it was rough enough that in you know
fifth grade i would come home and
make a vodka gimlet to have you know
de-stress from the day
um but uh
that also produces a lot of unhappiness
and so
when the kind of psychedelia of the time
suggested uh turning towards spiritual
solutions
uh we were all gung-ho and went into it
i went there was also there's also the
sort of financial aspect of pursuing
alternative spiritual practices tm was
also very popular that was the the
practice that the
uh the maharishi was offering to the
beatles and
uh to get your mantra at that time was
400
400 in 1968 was a lot of money
way more than i could get my hands on
and so i went
to the cafeteria of northwestern
university which was in the town i grew
up in
and talked to college student into
giving me his mantra even though it's
supposed to be
kept secret and practiced with that for
a while and developed
concentration from that and that was
useful
but the addiction swept way
right over that and really didn't
produce much in terms of
awakening
so um i
[Music]
left home and lived on the street for
about
15 months or so that was harrowing i
tended to think of it at the time as my
great
sort of vagabond adventure but it was
actually just living on the street
homeless which was not great
after all
i came home and uh one of the things
about
living on the street is that it's really
boring and
so i decided that i needed to do
something that would make living on the
street less boring and so
i decided that if i could learn how to
take photographs i could document my
experience living on the street and that
would be really interesting
so i came home and i uh my parents were
willing to pay for college but nothing
else really
and so i enrolled in a community college
and took a
class on photography but that became so
interesting to me that
living on the street no longer had an
appeal and so i then began pursuing
my art education so in chicago
i went to the chicago academy of fine
arts because i could just apply and get
in
my my high school transcript was rather
poor except my sat scores were pretty
good for the time
and so uh i met byron grush at
chicago academy who if you lived in
chicago you might know he's an
underground
filmmaker really interesting guy and
really expanded my understanding of what
that could be
then i went to the art institute i'm
i'm really more attracted to teachers
and what they have to show me
than i am to curriculums or degrees and
so i've
i have never gotten a degree but i have
gotten a lot of credits
i went to mexico for a while came back
the my attempts to get my family uh
situation to work better failed and so i
moved to new york
i'm answering your questions so don't
worry uh i'm enjoying it
uh gabe i'm a gay man so uh
uh and uh it's very different now than
it was
then um when you came out
uh when it went in your early 20s which
is when some people did it
i did it a little earlier than that you
just reconciled to the fact that
your family and your friends would
abandon you and you would have to start
over
it was one of the big hitches and people
coming out
you had to make a decision about being a
second class citizen and accepting that
and you had to make a decision of losing
everyone you've ever loved in order to
pursue this other thing so that
other thing has to be really important
to do
i went to new york and uh
it turned out to be a really uh
spectacularly good time to go there
uh they're talking about that period of
new york the the sort of the second half
of the 70s
into the early 80s as a period
of artistic expression equivalent to
paris in the 20s
so if you can imagine i had a 1400
square foot
loft on 11th and broadway which i paid
174 dollars a month for
so i four years ago when i was in new
york it was for brent and i
looked it up it was 8 500 a month so you
you can see the difference in that so we
only had to work two days a week and
then we could spend the other five days
a week
running around creating art and so there
was this
real explosion of expression at that
time wow
i like to say that that period ended
because of
aids crack and finance finance being the
most pernicious of them all
obviously and so in the gay community at
that time
when uh you'd had this first burst of
freedom and you could actually be open
about who you were and actually make
relationships uh around uh uh an
authentic expression of who you were as
best you could
you know if you grow up gay
and you identify it early in your life
you also grow up to learn how to pretend
to be someone else
because the consequences of coming out
at that time were so severe
so it creates a fracture in
in self-identity
um and so we have this burst of an
enormous creative energy this burst of
social
connection really
a very intense and beautiful
time which then is
consumed by a pandemic or
not a pandemic in the sense or an
epidemic of
an incurable disease that's a hundred
percent fatal
different than this pandemic right this
pandemic is three percent
fatal but if you can contrast that to
the idea of a
if you get infected you die uh very
different
and it it really went through the
community in it
in a devastating way quite different in
terms of the response
of the government reagan was president
and he said nothing a hundred thousand
people died before they made a statement
and it wasn't the president making the
statement
it was his press secretary who said that
aids is god's punishment for
homosexuality that was the
the government response and so the
community came together to
attend to the people who were sick and
dying and it was a
a very scary death
cycle the complete failure of your
immune system and it was also happening
to young people
in a way that was quite alarming you
know
the the people that i were was uh caring
for when they died were in their 20s
um beautiful you know you know this we
talked about it a little bit the 20s is
such a vibrant interesting time as
people
come out of the childhood come out of
the adolescence into
who they're going to be really an
extraordinary time
and so that moment was the moment that
the shift happened and i recognized that
i needed to go
in in a direction that would provide
a deep spiritual connection to make
sense out of what was happening
i i had gotten sober already
i got sober when i was
24. i got i had cirrhosis of the liver
when i was 23. my younger brother
was killed in a motorcycle accident and
the loss was unbearable and
my drinking accelerated to the point
that i was
uh i had stage three cirrhosis when i
was 23.
so overachiever
so got sober at 24 and then
in my late 20s of course it was just
attending to the
the the deaths
one death after another uh if you can
picture it imagine every three months
going to the funeral of one of your
close friends
for years
with no support in fact ridicule
and derision from society at large so
that was that
period and the the the place
where i turned toward finding some kind
of
spiritual understanding of what was
happening
wow
fifth grade drinking yeah
i was difficult to manage and so my dad
medicated me with
pharmaceuticals and they turned a blind
eye to the drinking
and then there was a
year and a half of homeless
not quite 15 months
and the picking up of the camera along
the way getting into
photography getting into art
and then moving to new york
and then
yes a funeral every three months is
devastating yeah
yeah i mean there's an equivalency now
which is really the opioid epidemic
um particularly in the addiction
community where
because
you know the politics of addiction in
this country are
difficult but
what happened was that because
the pharmaceutical companies managed to
get the government to pay retail prices
for
pain killers for chronic pain
they became available everywhere at
reasonable prices
but when you were buying them on the
street you were actually buying
manufactured
pharmaceutical company manufactured
products
so you could rely on what the packaging
was
when the when the epidemic
exploded and people began to respond to
it by demanding that the drug companies
stopped selling
so much of this stuff they began to
tighten the screws on it you you may
remember a few years ago the government
stopped paying for the pharmaceuticals
which was
the driver of the pharmaceutical side of
the
epidemic then the bootlegs came in
and the bootlegs were made with fentanyl
which is really unpredictable
and you need small quantities of it to
overdose from it
and so there's a surge of overdoses that
have come from the closing off of the
easy access to genuine pharmaceuticals
into bootleg pharmaceuticals
and so in that community
the the desert are equivalent in a way
to what the aids deaths were
and they have the same difficulty
integrating that constant loss
and they are also in the position of
being derided by society as a whole
as as drug addicts right and so they
don't really get
much support in that way
yeah there's a lot of perverse
incentives that are being
healed right now with
better goal congruence around inclusive
stakeholding and
maximizing our potential
rather than being extractive and this
has a lot to do with spiritual awakening
which we'll talk about
you had a lot of suffering
that created the
shift which is a very common
archetype is the roots reaching down to
hell so that the branches
can blossom towards the heavens
but yeah this started in fifth grade
really and then it
liver cirrhosis 23
all these deaths
and just having that
pivotal
shift so where did you go was that when
you went to
l.a you stayed did you stay longer no i
was still in new york
um i actually uh discovered
uh trump rinpoche
um so naropa i'd already known about
naropa because naropa was one of the
choices that
sort of the deep hippie divers
uh went to for school
i had some problems with
my capacity to trust anyone let's put it
that way
i found him untrustworthy as a person to
to make a teacher but i enjoyed the
writings and i
i practiced on my own so i would call it
a period of being a dharma orphan
um i was very interested in the
teachings very interested in the reading
but i was very uncomfortable
becoming intimate with anybody or
trusting anybody
or believing that they wouldn't in some
way turn around and exploit me
so i always stayed at a distance
but i had friends we also did some
journeying into the red road i don't
know if you've
done any of the
spiritual practices of
[Music]
native people but so we did a lot of
sweat lodges and
those kinds of ceremonies that was quite
interesting
in terms of the the the willingness to
become
open and also in the beginning
of course the extreme uh experience
shatters the the the ego
shatters the self and it just disappears
and then you're in this place of
freedom from the experience of self and
if you've always been confined by the
experience of self it's an amazing
freedom
of course the self comes back as soon as
the difficult circumstances are abated
but
you do have that breath there that
moment of
freedom and it's in the dark
and if you're sitting say we we sat with
uh for some ceremonies with
a medicine man from north dakota and he
was
just incredibly magical in terms of the
experience that we had
of course as my meditation practice
deepened my capacity for equanimity and
severe physical trials
got so great that the self was very
happily bobbing along the whole time
[Laughter]
that was less magical
and then there's this kind of bonding
that comes when
when you're sitting with people and
they're dying and they know they're
dying and uh
and they're in pain and
and uh you you can open to that if you
want to
and so there was a lot of that kind of
caring
i didn't get infected but i don't know
why because i certainly
behaved in the same way that everyone
else did
and there was that sort of puzzling
piece
you weren't here for that lesson you
were here to
continue onward and share what you're
sharing now with people around the world
so what happened is new york became a
haunted place for me everywhere i went
it would activated the grieving and
there was really no place to go
i had started an internet business uh
in the late 80s and
when the 1989 recession hit uh
the company went under and so i had my
last
10 grand and new york was haunted and i
decided that i'll i know i'll come to
los angeles and write screenplays
that seems like a good idea
so that's what i did i was a filmmaker
you know in new york
and we made these underground movies and
we showed them in
different places different clubs and
i quite enjoyed that uh that process
uh non-narrative film making which was
sort of the early chicago uh
instructions i had and then
my reflux which is what the cough is
and then i decided to go into narrative
stuff
anyway i came to los angeles and
decided to write screenplays in 1992
and
yes we have we have some uh this is
um george's the lower
manhattan dormitory effect
and this is some of his a memoir of 1979
new
york in photographs in lyric pro's
poetry and there's
other essayists that are in this as well
but it's very beautiful he gifted this
to me when he came and
there's a lot of the
what he's referencing right now so
it is so the the book is divided into
three sections the first section is
called the lower manhattan dormitory
effect
and my first reputation in new york was
as a poet and so
uh and i wrote lyric prose poetry and so
the first
section of the book is this long poem
that i wrote in new york
that i finished in 1983 which describes
that period of new york from the late
70s to the
mid-80s and then the middle part of the
book
or a series of portraits that i made
of the social group that i was in most
of the people
in the photographs died at that time
from aids
so you'll see at the the front of the
book there's a dedication to the
the circle of friends that i lost
and then the third part of the book is
called
chicago is not new york los angeles
is neither one which is the
the answer to the question you've really
just asked me
say the last say the last line again
chicago
is not new york los angeles is neither
one
so it's a description of uh
moving from chicago to new york and then
moving from new york to los
angeles and the spiritual
journey that happened that was john
john kemp who died in 1981 he was the
first one
so if you remember your aids history
aids wasn't actually identified until
1984 but people started dying the summer
of 79 which is why i
chose 79 to be the subject of the book
and at that time it was just an
unexplained cancer that was
uh killing people
and then it was a gay related immune
deficiency
syndrome and then they discovered hiv
so
and for those that are also interested
in this
this is on is this available on
meadowgroup.org as well
it is and you can also get it on amazon
and there's also an e-book version of it
if
if you don't want the paper although
it is a beautiful book so you might
consider it
those are before and after pictures in
case one of the great amusements
of of the of the book cover
is that uh there's a picture of me now
and then there's a picture of me when i
was 25
let's say and everyone says
i recognize you who's that
yeah exactly at first
the joy of aging i like to call that
yeah he told me
when he walked in he was like you're
gonna age like this too if you're lucky
right
yeah you don't today
so
so there was a period of documenting
and doing film in this late
70s early 80s
while the craziness was happening in new
york of identifying
what even was happening with hiv and
aids and then
there was a entering into this internet
era and
when you hit the recession packing up
and you had been exploring spirituality
you had turned towards
spirituality and had been exploring that
and then there was this
i'm gonna go and continue doing film in
l.a
and then getting here
then there was a process of also sort of
recalibrating when you came here because
that was
was that like 15 years in new york 16
okay and then here i've lived here
longer than anywhere else
in fact i've lived in my current
apartment longer than i've lived
anywhere
else and i came out here to write
screenplays and i
went at it pretty hard and uh i had
i guess two or three years where i was
supporting myself doing that and then
i got a feature film uh which
uh uh it's called friends and lovers is
starring robert downey jr steve baldwin
and
claudia schiffer suzanne cryer's in it
um danny newchie's in it anyway
we made the movie it was released and it
didn't do well
uh critically or financially and i got
thrown into uh director's jail which i
never
i was able to figure out a way out of
and so
that also uh put an end to my
screenwriting
efforts but
i also at that time wanted to begin to
address
the difficulties that were dogging me
from my childhood so
i don't know what the stock you put in
western
psychological definitions of
mental health issues but i was diagnosed
with
dissociative identity disorder in the
early 90s
and it was a good explanation for me
because it made sense why everything was
so difficult
and so then i went into this process of
trying to work through that
and at the time it was really a
mostly direct trauma reprocessing of
really no understanding at all of
attachment or attachment theory
and so it was a very difficult period of
four or five years of
working through that when i really
didn't have a bandwidth to do much else
so coming through that process
and so
out of that process uh the the main
advantage of that was that i couldn't
really get anything to happen in my
film life uh while i was so
uh dissociative and working through the
dissociation then allowed me to
get my first feature to be made and then
the feature didn't do well and so i
didn't get to work
beyond that you know the as we like to
say the film business is
one strike baseball and so
you either hit or you don't so
i needed to then imagine
a different life
i think that what we really want to
pursue
in our lives is finding a sense of
meaning or finding a sense of value in
it
and most of the
the typical rewards of our society
which i experienced in my childhood you
know an upper class
upper middle class upbringing is
very materially rich it was also uh
so as i like to say a well-appointed
torture chamber half the time and so
that wasn't appealing to me i never was
interested in
in pursuing any of that and i had
uh suffered so greatly i was really
focused on trying to find
a way of being alive that actually had
some sense of value to me some sense of
peacefulness and so
i had started meditating when i came
to la and uh down in venice at a place
called
ordinary dharma with katriana reed
and uh i was you know my typical
untrusting self and they weren't
kind enough for me and so i moved back
into a period of
dharma orphan hood and
then the next teacher i tried was
shinzen and he actually
miraculously was kind enough
for me to be willing to sit with him as
a teacher
what does that mean kind enough during
that time
i wanted somebody who would just allow
me to be the way that i was without
demanding that i be different than i was
the radical acceptance of exactly where
you were at right
that's what i wanted and i didn't want
to have to believe
anything and i didn't want
to have to reveal more than i wanted or
was comfortable revealing
and and he was okay with that all of
that
you know i i i'm um think of myself as a
clever person and i would
set up these elaborate uh obstacle
courses
for teachers to get through that may be
a better way of putting it
where you could fail at any moment and
be slaughtered and
he was the only one who up to that time
had managed to get through that
i think also it coincided with a lot of
the
the work on the dissociation that i was
doing
um he also is i like to say
an over explainer i am and we had some
of this in our conversation
earlier i'm much more interested in the
how to do it than what you're supposed
to do
i want to know how you do it exactly
step by step
tiny little steps to describe the
process
and he does that which is really so it's
another reason why i
studied with dan brown he he's in the
pointing out the great way tradition
which is
uh just really uh descriptive of exactly
how to do it not what you're supposed to
do
which i find too general and and not
helpful most of the time
and then that's also how i teach it's
not uncommon for
somebody to say uh stop over explaining
but for somebody like me um i'm dyslexic
i'm dyspraxic i'm dysgraphic i'm just
calculate
learning is an arduous slow
process for me and i need all of that
support in order
to understand i do get to go deep
because of that but the
things that aren't descriptive enough
aren't helpful
i love this i love this focus right now
so okay so
since oops no worries
[Music]
awesome just move it a little bit closer
again like that
excellent i love this focus on
the difference between what you're
supposed to do versus how you're
supposed to do it
i love this yeah shinzon does have a
heavy focus on how and so does dan brown
and
that makes sense that then you ended up
picking up
that as well and that it worked for you
given where
you had come from in your life
let's have a little bit of a breakdown
let's use the
example of quieting the noisy mind which
is a very common example
so the what
pointing is to say quiet the mind
and then the how pointing is to say use
your breath
and become aware of the space in which
the clouds of thoughts arise and
disappear
is that about a good example
i would say you don't have to quiet your
mind
okay all right i don't like that
that oh what do you have to do right
okay so you
just go straight to the how yeah and so
there's no
what of quiet the mind or still the mind
or
become aware of space or emptiness
it's just the how particularly in the
beginning when you can't do it anyway
okay so then even that hole so but
isn't the utility of putting the star
into place of where we're heading
with the how so what i would say is you
don't have to steal the mind you just
have to be able to maintain
concentration
so what we're going to work on is you
letting the whole mind be as busy it's
ever been
and just being able to pinpoint your
concentration and hold awareness of that
and we'll use the breath
so pick a place on the breath where you
want to watch it tip of the nose opening
of the mouth back of the throat rising
of the chest rising of the belly take a
look now
see where you can really detect that
sensation easily
and then we'll put your attention there
and may i ask for our
audience and for just the
cadence of taking this a little bit
slower because
you're going through it like you've been
teaching
for 18 years and so
um yeah let's take it
i would go that fast actually with a new
studio
[Laughter]
okay give us all of these they don't
have time to location
[Laughter]
where in the how are all of the
different locations
because there's a very common
recognizing in the traditions of
example in vipassana where you can
become aware
on the very nostril itself and on the
very top of
the mouth itself and become aware of
which nostril
the inhalation is coming into so let's
go through that those examples one more
time well i just
okay then bring your attention to the
tip of your nose
i don't know what they they think the
tip of the nose is
so i'm going to let them tell me what
the tip of the nose is for them
so then i can agree or disagree with
their description of the tip of the nose
after i know what their
description is oftentimes if you
are too uh directive
they shut down their own exploration and
attempt to discover what you're
directing them to discover
and what i want them to do is discover
what their experience is not what
i think they should be having
so tip of the nose opening of the mouth
what's the opening of the mouth like can
you what do you feel
what's the experience of that and then
they'll tell me
and then i can direct them to a better
choice or just accept the choice that
they have if it's good enough
what is it like to feel the breath in
the back of the throat and then they'll
tell me
what is it like to feel the rising of
the chest and then they'll tell me and
then what is the
and so you give them the time here where
you say
what does it feel like as the chest
rises and then they respond right okay
so you ask the question
that's basically guiding their attention
into a more relaxed
state and they're responding to every
single one of your guidances with how
they feel about the experience right
describing their experience which is a
meditative experience
right what you're trying to get them to
have right off the bat
is a meditation experience not an idea
of what a meditation experience
should be and then i say
which of those is the easiest for you to
track
and then they tell me so i don't have to
assign anything
they're they're doing the exploration
they're assigning their attention
and then i say just watch that
and
if you get caught up in thinking as soon
as you recognize it
don't beat yourself up just come
immediately back
as many times as you need to there's no
limit
and in fact i would bet as a new
meditator
90 plus percent of the time you're going
to be caught up
but the coming back is actually the
practice of meditation so you're doing
it right
yes yes i'm big on you're doing it right
and then what you notice is once you
begin to develop
concentration that the mind quiets so i
don't even need to tell them about that
they discover it on their own
and then this is something that's very
human
it's more valuable because they've
discovered it then because i told them
that that's what they should be looking
for okay
interesting
so
so we have a
we'll go ahead and see if this shot
gives you guys a
yeah an okay visualization of it so what
we do
is we start off with directly into
meditative experience being guided with
the how
and so then there are these
the the pointing is
done experientially with each sentence
having a response from
the student that is being guided about
how it feels so there is a deep level of
engagement and presence right with the
experience
so there's no blah blah blah blah blah
and the student's mind is wandering and
not paying any attention
but also how do you know whether the
student has understood your instructions
yes if you don't ask them then they
don't tell you how they've understood
immediately afterward every sentence is
being
confirmed that the student is
understanding or not
right every sentence that's really
that's really great okay so now
we're getting really we're getting taken
through the core part of the how
and then sentence by sentence confirming
around our feeling of the experience and
then
we're bringing that attention that very
focused
as the mind wanders we bring it back and
naturally the mind quiets in that
process so interesting so rather than
in a sense
being told the what of
mind quiet
and putting that in the north star
position and then undergoing the process
of
here's the experience of all right so
let's use the breath
as our tool to get to this place of
stillness
that we've put into the position and
there's a really
kind of nice little hand guiding step by
sentence by sentence step by step
around the direct experience of what is
being felt with the breath
as the tool that creates the quieting of
the mind in a very guided way
right cool
which is basically what is you know what
is
taught in the mystic traditions but
there is
a lot of
there's a lot of noise in terms of when
[Music]
a
not direct
one-on-one personalized guided
jedi-like guidance is happening
because if it's not that what it is is
it's very general is what happens it's
really general
and i've
noticed that through some of the times
that
i've went through
like a netty nettie not this not that
meditation
guiding it for our audience that
it's resonant and helps people
but it's very general because it's not
being personalized hey
how you doing on this step okay so
you're here on this step
how about you okay you're here on that
step now confirm
okay so you have you're not your mind
you're not your body you're not your
name
and so that is not available because
it's just the direct
one hour to generally to the eyes
so i see there's a big difference then
when you take like 10 or 20 people
you do you go one on one
how do you do that well one of the
things that i notice in the west
is that most of the meditation
instruction is coming from authors
and really they're going around on book
tours selling their books
and doing sort of helicopter teachings
is what i
think of it is which is lovely and it
creates this this discussion about it
but if you want to engage beyond the
very beginning of practice you need to
be in a relationship with a teacher
who can give you the level of guidance
that you need and really understand what
your experience is and so
at meta group one of the things we offer
is this one-on-one meditation mentoring
and so people check in twice a month
with me and i remember what they're
doing and i remember the
instructions that they've been given and
they report on me
in a very burmese style you know this
happened then that happened then that
happened then that happened then that
happened then that happened then that
happened
what do you think and so then we get
into a dialogue
and then we adjust the practice and then
people have a period of time to practice
and then they come back
and uh people do tend to make
a faster progress if that's something
that they want
and also they feel more supported
sometimes when you come out of the
belief
if in conceptual reality and you begin
to see things the way that they really
are
it's very disorienting one of the things
that i
suggest to people is that the more
inauthentic you are
in the way that you operate your life
the harder all of this is going to be
for you
because not only will you get to a place
where you won't be able to do the
inauthenticity anymore
but the people that you've been
inauthentic with will be
furious at you for being inauthentic
with them
and so you have to be able to moderate
that in a way that
people can adapt as you become more
capable of
coming into an authentic expression so
there's often in the theravada world
this conversation around dark knight but
i
uh or dark knight is a christian term
knowledge of the miseries is the
buddhist term
that you see that there is no self and
if you've hung your sense of
security on their being one it's
frightening
there nothing lasts you can't count on
anything
and if you can't adapt to that being the
way that it is
then it's miserable you're sad
the things that you cling to the goals
that you thought would make you happy
don't work
and you can see that it isn't that it
hasn't always been like that and that
you haven't been in this
confusion about what is actually
happening
but that part still takes a sort of an
integration and then you know you live
in a human body that's going to grow old
get sick and die and there's nothing you
can do about it
except find humor
[Laughter]
in the aging process because it's a camp
um so then
you come out to the other side of that
of course then you see clearly how it is
and that puts you at this crossroads in
one direction is nihilism right
nothing matters it's not going to last i
can't really have anything
it's not worth doing anything and the
other direction which is actually the
one i'm recommending
i do sometimes recommend things that you
go for full engagement
all in in every moment as much as you
can
because if you withhold yourself
to avoid the disappointment of losing it
which you're going to do anyway
you don't have the engagement you just
have the losing it which
you're pretty much guaranteed to have so
that's this
this open eyes open fully engaging
each moment in this authentic expression
and what comes from that
is this meaningfulness this richness at
being alive
it's amazing to live that way
and when you contrast it to the
self-limiting uh approach that is very
common the protective
approach the need for a sense of
artificial
safety what you get out of that of
course is despair
and when you when you can see them side
by side
why would you ever pick despair over
this vibrant aliveness
francis lucille calls it the eternal
fireworks
so are you going to enjoy the eternal
fireworks
may as well yeah totally
yeah sorry
the coughing is just in the spring
so
i have a couple questions one of them is
what about self-inquiry or the direct
path becoming aware of awareness
getting investigating what is i
or who is me what about
the questioning
the self questioning the i or the me
itself
i think it's a useful practice
there's a few ways to talk about it um
when i was first sitting with shinzen he
said the the self no self experience is
like
a walled garden on in the inside of the
wall it's an immaculate
completely trimmed super maintained a
beautiful garden and on the outside of
the wall it's just a complete
jungle and there's a gate that goes
through the wall and you can move
from the manicured garden to the jungle
and that liberation would actually be
able to come and go between the two
whenever you wanted
so if you needed to manifest a brilliant
sense of self
you could do it like that and then if
you didn't need it anymore you could
just let it go
and what ends up happening of course is
in the beginning you're trapped on one
side of the gate or the other and you
can't operate the lock
and then you get better at operating the
lock and you can come and go but
sometimes it gets stuck sometimes you
get stuck in self and you immediately
see how
the suffering is so intense
mind blowingly intense and then you go
into the
the no self side and you see that you
you have no
motivation to do anything that you could
sit on a bench for a week and
not move but it would be fine
as householders which we are neither one
of those approaches is going to be very
good and so you want to really get good
at moving between
the two sasaki roshi used to say
my job as a meditation teacher is a
travel agent
taking you effortlessly from heaven to
hell
so that back and forth if you looked at
it from a more tibetan
uh perspective it would be the an
emptiness
frame where each time you get caught up
in a sense of self and you notice the
suffering that arises there
find the sense of self that is suffering
and what you discover of course is you
can't locate it
and then what you see is this uh
awareness knows a pattern of sensory
experience which is
identifiable itself much in the way that
anger or
happiness would be identified as a
pattern of sensing experience and it
it takes on no more importance than
that sense of any uh
conceptual version of sensing experience
and then then you're in freedom one of
the things that's interesting
in contrasting that is in holding that
open awareness
open awareness is a tricky term because
in the theravada world it means
something different
than in the tibetan world but um
if you come into profound uh no
self-state
using the teravata path then you don't
fix
any fixate anything so if you were
talking to me and i was in a profound no
self state i wouldn't
fixate the sound of your voice and it
would just be vibration
and i wouldn't understand what you were
saying to me and i would be able to
respond to you from wisdom mind
from that that everything
but i wouldn't be able to understand
what i was saying
and i wouldn't be able to make a memory
of our experience together
and it no from a neuroscience
perspective
depending on the technique you do it has
a different effect on the brain and so
if you shut down
the capacity to form autobiographical
memory then you don't
remember anything this is not that
practical
in householder life
if you go from the tibetan view where
you just hold this huge expansive
consciousness this conscious awareness
then you see all of these activities
rising in this giant experience
and then you do remember what happens
which i actually have a preference for
because it's easier
to manage it's for instance uh
um years of being interviewed by shinzen
when he's in this
no self state he doesn't remember
anything about the interview and so
it's always a one-off experience which
i've
i've never found helpful uh really
whereas with uh you can be in a state of
both no self and having
memory to be a good travel agent
right exactly so that's that's the
difference
so then when you when you work with
somebody who uh
is uh in you know
uh wisdom mind
not identified at all with a sense of
self
but at the same time able to to
allow the formation of conceptual
reality to the point that you can
understand the language that
you're using and how people are
responding
i find it it has a greater utility let's
put it that way
definitely yeah
yeah i call these crevices
it's almost as though the
all of these different faces
to the one end all these many paths to
this one
end and truth being this pathless land
and
the always already free perfection that
we are
just this already is awakening
the very nature of
having this
as you go up in this awakening process
to have these
crevices that are like big
amounts of snow that you don't actually
know
fall into this 50-foot crevice that
nobody's gonna find you and you'll die
in a sense the crevices are like this
you get to be whatever expression of
infinity you want to be and that is
coming through
to be but that if you fall
into this crevice where you
abide in this perpetual no self
no symbolism no memory
have whatever
understanding of the unique expression
that you are but remember that
your bodhisattva is not going to be as
potent
so your travel agent ability
is not going to be as potent and
to be a travel agent or to be a
bodhisattva to be this
sort of jedi that's able to navigate
across all these different lenses of
non-duality duality individuation
awakening popping into awareness popping
into source
void emptiness being infinity
do you know how to navigate all of that
or are you stuck
parroting a specific
so i found that the more
of a travel agent you are the more
you're actually able to be
a shepherd or a steward of the creations
awakening
yep
one of the things that i notice is that
in the beginning practice is very
oriented around
personal suffering and the pursuit of
the relief of personal suffering
but that that isn't that hard
then you see in the distance
happiness jumping on the horizon and you
think oh i'll go for happiness and then
you
go after happiness and then
that's not that hard and then you see
freedom and you go for that that's a
little harder
but it's it is actually totally worth
doing
and then it was hilarious because it was
here the whole time
well that's a bummer
you know his dad says which i this is
the metaphor i quite like
it's cloudy does that mean the sun isn't
shining
so very simple sweeping away the
obscurations that prevent you from
seeing
um so then it also depends a lot on
what the conditioning is did you ever
play a game called minesweeper
[Laughter]
i liken it to that
you sometimes you click on a square and
half the board opens up and it's totally
effortless and sometimes you click
on a square and every single square
around you has a high number
and you click on in the game blows up so
the conditioning for everybody is
different and it really is dependent on
what happened
and so the one-size-fits-all does it
really help because
everybody's conditioning is different
and so then you need to be able to
meet the person and their conditioning
and then find
patience i'm not a particularly patient
person but
um i i do find
that i can find compassion for people
if they're actually ardent in their
effort
there's a lot of value in
the very meticulous howness
of training attention and using the
breath as the tool
huge benefit insane
utility and we'll talk about this
like we did in the first hour before we
started the podcast
where there's a tremendous utility in it
in
entrepreneurship and in science and
engineering
and creativity and even your
relationship with your spouse or your
kids your friends
just the pause in itself and training
the non-reactivity but the
observer or the witnessing creates
this joy and peace
rather than the needing to force the
perspective into everything
so that in itself has extreme utility
even in the practical
matrixy infrastructures
yet that
is
overly done in the sense of
nobody ever sometimes tells
meditators to
get off of the cushion and not only to
investigate the nature of who is it that
is even meditating
first of all right so you're a person
that's meditating and then you never
question what it means to be a person
you never question life itself you never
question
what your source is and if your identity
is actually
the very source and force of creation
and that can propel this no-self
so there's that and then there's also
the component of get off of the cushion
and weave your realizations into society
can meditation be when you're at a
grocery store and you're
checking out and you're smiling and
you're
holding the space of emptiness and
joy and peace while you're in your
engagement with
the person that's checking you out
the checker
i think one of the reasons that i
gravitated to shinzon and also to dan is
that
the main practice is the practice in
life the cushion is just
training yourself to be able to do it
well enough so that you can take it out
but the emphasis was always on
taking it out it was never in in
withdrawing onto the cushion and so
uh all of the just instructions you'll
get for me or from them would be
that this is just the formal practice is
just training you so that you can take
it out in life
and the majority of the practice is as a
practice in life
so that that actually has never been
um much of a concern
of mine because um that's never
the the teachers that i would was drawn
to
um never taught that
so um
so to piggyback a little bit on the
conversation about concentration when i
started teaching at a meditation center
in los angeles i was trying to teach
basic shinzen techniques
one of the things about western practice
is that most of the instruction that you
get in meditation
in the early period so this is for say
the 70s
on was based on retreat practice so you
went to a retreat and you learned to
practice and so
we call it dry vapasana i'm a medeva
pass and a teacher mainly so that's what
we
talk about you don't do any uh
preliminary concentration practice
because you sit on these long retreats
and in meditating for hours
and hours every day the concentration
develops just as
a de facto quality of that kind of
practice
and then you can go into the insight
practice when i was teaching in the
meditation center
you know 90 plus percent of people
never went on retreats and so the basics
the super basic shinzon techniques
were too difficult to do
and so what was really happening is that
people were sitting on the cushion
and having daydreaming experiences
not meditation experiences because they
didn't have the preliminary capacity to
do the simplest
meditation techniques and so when i
began to teach
i began to to impose concentration
practice
as a prerequisite for insight practice
and it was a
simple fix people sit
and do preliminary concentration
practices for a couple of months then
they have access concentration
and they can zoom along on their inside
practices
that if they don't do the preliminary
practices they never really get
to see the potential of
yes agreed and this is also where the
scenarios have happened where you'll
take somebody that gains
a little bit of insight into the
the nature of everything already being
free and perfect
and yet they'll still have ego flare-ups
right
yeah so then the other thing that would
happen is that people would get into
areas of unresolved psychological
difficulty
from doing the insight techniques and
they wouldn't know how to manage them
and the intensity of the experiences
would often be so negative that they
would withdraw from meditation
altogether
for a period of time then the suffering
would grow we talked about this earlier
and then when the suffering again
propelled them to start practicing and
they would practice again but they would
be in this cycle of
some practice some intense practice then
no practice
so what i discovered was that what
was most beneficial was to develop this
capacity
for of the heart so that you develop the
capacity to be kind to yourself you
develop the capacity to be compassionate
for the experiences you had
you develop your capacity for joyfulness
and for balance so that if something
happens in the inside side of practice
you can
rush back into the heart practices and
have this container to settle
and come back into a place of kindness
for yourself
it's very common excuse me
in western practitioners to have a very
harsh
relationship to the self and when you
get into the vipassana side it can act
activate that and then they're having
this experience of
you know severe self-criticism in the
meditation
and uh and completely derailing it
and so in this met of a past and
integrated practice you come in
and the first practice is you do develop
this capacity for kindness
so uh the way that dan brown frames it
is
these are two separate systems there is
the system for
for negative experience and the system
for positive experience
you can do all of this work to
limit the intensity of the negative
experiences but if you don't
do work to intentionally improve the
capacity for positive experience
that never develops and so it is this
balance between
really pumping up the positive
experiences and your capacity to
tolerate very positive experiences and
mitigating the negative experiences that
actually make
the more advanced practices easier to do
because often
the the intensity of the bliss
experiences that come
from more advanced practice are
overwhelming for people
and they don't experience overwhelming
emotion as
positive they experience it as difficult
or troublesome
and so you these early practices need to
be there so that
when you are hit with a bliss bomb say
you can just be delighted that you're in
this bliss bomb and not
completely derailed and suddenly spin
into anxiety
instead of just being able to bliss out
for a while
interesting almost as though when the
bliss bomb hits
and you're rolling on the floor laughing
and you're just collapsed on the
sidewalk laughing
at the ineffable perfection and freedom
that are you anxious about how other
people are looking at you
and that would be the disaster
rather than being able to see that that
is the same one intelligence
looking at the another component of the
one
intelligence and that way then there's
no anxiety
right and so then there's freedom
there's freedom
even if that person is in the matrix and
they're looking
with why are you happy they're the bliss
police and they're
and they're angry that you see the
entirety of the hole
and rather than having that yeah that's
critical
we have emotions we have emotional
regulation systems most of the time
we regulate our emotions through
thinkings or repetitive thoughts
we have a negative experience and it
exceeds the window of tolerance that's a
dan siegel
frame then the mind will use the
regulation strategies it has to regulate
that
if you have an intensely negative
experience and you use this harsh
self-talk to regulate it the mind will
turn on the self-talk
and it takes you out of the present
moment
into thinking and that's the process of
regulation
if you have a very intense positive
emotion it exceeds your window of
tolerance
the mind is going to look to the
database for how to regulate it
and if you use very harsh self-criticism
to regulate
positive experience that exceeds your
capacity to hold it
you're going to go from very positive to
very critical
because the body mind will have to
regulate and so you really want to
part of this investigation is to see
what you're doing
so that you can make the adjustments to
the system so that will
you'll get to a place where you can
actually support the the the
uh deep advanced practice because if you
don't do it
the system that's in place is just not
going to allow it
so the vast majority of this can also be
boiled down to
patterns and becoming aware
of the patterns and also becoming more
sovereign in the
scripts that are running taking
a neurobiological
angle on this and doing it from
[Music]
a
a place of wanting to know one's true
nature
above all else and being so
earnest in that process that
you can get really good at the attention
practices and get really good at
understanding all of these components
but
also recognize that you can sort of
liberate yourself to this
state of recognizing that i
am the very empty
source that
has this very illusory sense of
i that experiences
infinite creation and if you sort of see
yourself as that very one intelligence
that is eternal that is infinite in its
creativity and that all of this is that
one intelligence and there is no
separation in there and you you're
perpetually come from a place of
how do i serve my own creation rather
than how do i extract
from it and so there's like if you can
pop to this
quote like last stage of awakening
and just begin seeing it all
as that one intelligence at play with
itself and then come from a place of
serving it
in a sense and stay perpetually empty
repeatedly abide in the very emptiness
experiencing the infinite creation and
also
abide in the place of serving coming
from a place of serving
the one intelligence then
a lot of the so-called
all these ways to talk about the mind
can in a sense be
you can transcend that and then
as it comes up you'll be ready for it
because you'll see it come up like you
described where you
see because you've trained this
vigilance
you see the more conditioned
personhood habit arise and
you
you can tell in a sense when there is a
a trajectory off of this very
empty sourcefulness in service to its
creation where the trajectory comes up
in its
this old pattern this old
script where it was trying to manipulate
or
extract some sort of validation
and so that's this
kind of coming from the place of wanting
to
radically accept know love and accept
yourself and the creation
exactly how it is and then pop to
the very sourceful
awakened state of this all being
one intelligence at play with itself and
then sort of dealing with
the conditionings as they
arise
it's like a direct path
popping
bird's way rather than this very
slow ants way but that has very
important components to it like we've
been talking about with
training the attention in a sense we've
also talked about this quite a bit but
the idea of neoadvitor or the so-called
you know direct pointing to this very
nature of
no self all being a dream
is very important and yet at the same
time
the mind being trained to sort of
become quiet really enables this
insight
and in doing so it
stabilizes the realization
and that stability of awakening
enables the travel agent
the very stableness to it
well that's the puzzle the the taste of
awakening is ordinary
everybody's probably had it they may not
recognize that that's what it is
but like you say it's always here and
it's very common it's ordinary
what's not ordinary is to be able to
stabilize the view of it
and so that's where everything gets in
the way and then how do you tackle that
process um
and as a practice in life for instance
dan tells a story that
uh he was had the taste of awakening and
his
teacher said that he needed to
stabilize it and so what he was going to
do was have him sit in the doorway of
the office and control the flow of
people who went in and out
while he was attempting to stabilize his
awakening
and that he would have to stay there
until it was stable
which is why in so many of the
enlightenment jokes it's
okay now go back home right and sit with
your family for a week
i also recommend that even if it's not
enlightenment because
if you can't recognize your own
conditioning you'll see it in them
yes and they have the same conditioning
you do if you want to know how you
regulate your emotions go home
and look at how everybody else is doing
it because you're doing it the same way
and then evaluate whether you think it's
a good way or a bad way and if it's a
bad way stop doing it
and if it's a good way reinforce it what
of course happens then
is that you have deficits of capacity to
regulate and then you have to train
yourself to regulate
in a different way so you want to train
yourself out of
afflictive emotional regulation
strategies into beneficial
strategies but you have to see them in
order to know what to do
and so that's that piece how do you how
do you see it and then from the point of
view of a teacher
it isn't useful to somebody for you to
describe to them how you see it
and tell them to look for that
what might be useful is describing the
process of how you
saw it and then suggesting that they
investigate how to see it which
they will know because their
conditioning is different than yours
and your conditioned responses are
different than theirs
and you can't point that out for them
they have to discover themselves so
in teaching somebody this stuff you have
to again and again
push them to examine what their
experience is
[Music]
particularly not
generally and not yours
one of the things i notice a lot in
teachers is that
they're very good at describing their
experience but they haven't figured out
that it isn't universal
the very nature of the travel agent is
what's most exciting or the bodhisattva
that which is really able to take
whatever confused seeking impulse
that is approached to the
entity and
be able to
[Music]
provide a really strong reflection
that creates a self-inquiry
on the entity's end
so that very
ability to learn how to
reflect and how to
stay quiet and still and empty until the
spontaneous
best effortless
words come
is something that i found to be
important to train
to abide in
i'd be curious do you feel
emptiness witnessing infinite creation
i would need to know what you mean
well how does that resonate with you
well
the main practice i'm doing now is
called self-rising self-liberating
and it's holding that expansive uh
experience
uh not so tightly that it just becomes
wordless soundless and not so loosely
that you get caught up in things
so that this process of being
dan describes it as it's as if you're
writing the message on water
you're able to detect the message but
you don't cling to it at all so it
disappears immediately so that's that
place of balance sulfurizing
and self liberating liberating
so in essence that
the very
infinite creation is having a
self-appearance and a self-liberation
and a self-appearance and a
self-liberation without any clinging
at all to any quote past or any quote
future
and just enjoy the very freedom and
perfection
yes stabilize that
[Laughter]
um
i say things like uh to dan
you know you have these elaborate
explanations of all of these things in
this elaborate
languaging of all of these things they
don't really resonate with me
and he says they don't need to yeah um
he also says that in the west science is
what's miraculous
and the miraculous is no longer
miraculous in that sense
so uh one of the things i like to do
when i go uh sit with the seda and myron
mar
is listen to his his tales of people
flying
and all sorts of that's funny that
people think that the
analysis of form is miraculous
it's kind of limiting so
when did we come to that understanding
yeah well it's a miracle the the very
fundamental unit of biology of the cell
is in fact a beautiful
miracle but at the same time
realizing emptiness is a miracle well
they are the faith in all of those
constructs which are really temporary uh
is what's hilarious yeah um
so the santo was describing this this
story of some students of his
um and the mother was old and moving too
slowly and they were impatient to go to
the festival and so
they informed her that she would have to
stay at home because she wasn't ready
and then they took a cab to the festival
and
she went into a moment of compassion and
practiced
her meta and then
the the bliss that arose
transported her and she flew across the
city and she arrived at the festival
before they did
[Laughter]
and immediately one of the german kids
in the front row said
could you demonstrate that for us now
yeah straight over the
zero set and then uh
i i said to the santa
quite a metaphor and he said
you have that sharp western mind
which means you can't see what's right
in front of you
yes that's such a good way to put it
which i had been laughing for days
wow what a good way to put it
the sharp western mind can't
even see what's it right in front of it
aka
the very screen on which all the
modulations happen
right so that's such a good way to
such a good way to put it
that's why my nervous system went into
shock and i just started crying in the
fetal position for like
10 straight minutes when the first pop
into
awareness aware of awareness happened
because it was right there the whole
[ __ ] time
i call it bittersweet bittersweet bitter
because that's
how it is sweet because you could do it
now you can do it
yeah yep
yeah that's the you really get the
the greatest of all time roomie
you go from room to room looking for the
diamond that's already around your neck
and then what is hilarious is that
then you go and you try and like
explain when people ask you know
like heal this confused seeking impulse
what do i do
and then like you ask
are you aware that you exist it's like
yes are you aware that you're aware
yes but it's so funny how fast it just
it's like you confirming of it
even for me you know five years ago
nobody asked me that exact question but
i just
that feeling of how quickly you just
dismiss
the fact of beingness or is-ness or
awareness or i am-ness how fast is just
dismissed how fast the god is just
dismissed
for the modulations of the screen itself
i am this i am that i am career
i am identity i am name i am form
that's where it all that's the whole
argument
right
and so the turn inward from all of that
is the cessation of the argument with
god
and the abiding in god itself
which then enables the purification
and it enables coming from a place of
service
rather than from a place of extraction
yeah and yeah it's just
it's right here you know just the screen
that you're watching the song
before it's
modulated
and it's the same thing with the very
you know
just take the very nature of
of the blank canvas
and just how many different ways can you
color this blank canvas with art
it's the same answer as how many
different ways can you modulate
the screen with images to make movies
just the level of subtlety with you
becoming aware of
that being the true nature is atrophied
it's atrophied the
the nature of the energetic contraction
is that it has atrophied its true nature
as the very source of the infinite
creation and it's in its contracted
personhood
and it's not focused on this
the very blank
screen or blank canvas
and rather it's focused on all of the
identity it's focused on the personhood
it's focused on
trying to extract peace and happiness
from
the creation rather than
recognize that it the nature of the
awareness itself is
peace and happiness i'd like to use a
quantum metaphor for that
please yes so in quantum mechanics of
course
in the moment all of the possibilities
are there
all of them limitless possibilities as
soon as you choose one the one that you
pick
becomes solid and all of the other
choices are lost
and then in the next moment everything
that's possible from the place you've
just chosen
opens and as soon as you pick one every
possibility except for the one you
picked falls away
and then that leads you to the next
moment where all of the moments that are
connected to the moment you're in that
we're connected to the preceding moment
open if you can see them
and if you can't see them what you see
is this very sort of
puny array of choices that you keep
picking
samsara this groove this rut where you
don't allow yourself to see
all of the possibilities that are there
just the ones that you're habitually
used to choosing
and so it creates the perception that
that's all that there is
even though all the time all of the
other choices were there
um which i think is is a useful
metaphor because in that moment where
you're heading down a sort of vicious
cycle what's opening in the moment is
all of the possibilities
including the virtuous cycle and you
could
without obligation to the direction of
going and choose something else
if you can see it yeah so that's the
training the training is to
open and then a lot of those choices
are going to have these conditioned
reactions of fearfulness or
disinterest we're always choosing things
that have high value to us as we select
what we
choose to make conceptual reality out of
and you know your list
of high value targets if you don't
evaluate it
might not have great things on it it
might be conditioned from your earliest
earliest experiences but they still
might not be that useful to you
and yet they're still on your list of
high-value targets and so
it's seeing that and then training the
mind out of it that often
creates the possibility of a view that
can then see the other choices
that it's obscured from seeing because
of that
yep the infinite possibility
is here and the contracted person
identity
sees one or two of the trajectories
right
and the liberated sees all of them
and working your way with
unfreezing the will the choice the
sovereignty from the
algorithms and scripts of those patterns
towards the liberated free
is just the relaxation of that
contracted identity relax it expand it
close the delta the gap between
the way that you see yourself as a
person and the way that god sees you
right now
does god have acceptance for the
creation exactly as it is
you were saying yes i'm just gonna say
exactly how
oh yeah yeah how to click exactly
so what is closing the gap and then
is everything that we've talked about so
far
yeah exactly how do i do that perfect
and that's what the simplified
spirituality is
is the is the how how to close the gap
from the person contracted energy
to the way that god loves its creation
and accepts its creation right now
exactly as it is
and again
as we brought up earlier
the very activity of
using the breath and becoming aware of
the breath the tool that's
always with you and becoming aware of
that
repeatedly and becoming aware of the
very sky
itself that is where
it all arises and passes
and then just walking each person sort
of through step by step
sentence by sentence that process and
checking how does it feel
right now and that's the really tailored
personalized approach
and that's very important versus
i like the word you used earlier
helicopter teachings
it's sort of a good way to put it
because i i really needed i would um
have an experience and i wouldn't be
able to integrate it
and then i would ask my teacher and they
would tell me what to do and then i
would do that and
see how it went and then in this
constant dialogue
move ahead and so that's really what i i
think the
the usefulness of of having a regular
dialogue with the teacher is
and then you don't actually need a
teacher who's
a full master if you're not at the
in advanced practice you just need
somebody's a little bit ahead of you
so that we can use uh people in our
community that are also practitioners so
uh it's also important to have
um a community of meditators that you're
connected to and in dialogue with
because i don't know about you but have
you ever tried to explain
esoteric meditation experience with
somebody who
believes in the solid world
doesn't go that good the question is
why did they ask to have it explained to
them
that's always the funny thing is ask
yourself you know
was i asked for this because if the
answer is no
then why are you sharing your gold with
somebody that's going to slap it out of
your hand
well i'll give you an example we were i
had a few people over
three hardcore meditators been
practicing for a long time
and one person uh who doesn't practice
before and
she was kind of sorceried
[Laughter]
the whole time it went well but you know
it was
whoa
[Laughter]
so if you
get into difficulty you need support
who's going to support you
if all of the people around you don't
know anything about meditation and don't
have any experience of working through
meditation experiences
how they're going to support you so then
you're unsupported and that tends to
slow practice down
so you need to have this community
around you that will support you the
sangha they call it
that supports you but also
you need somebody who is ahead of you
enough to be able to understand what's
happening
a lot of times particularly with the
dissolution experiences
people get really frightened by them and
they they have a
you know you hit a tipping point you're
not actually able to go back
to where the way it was before uh
and uh you know with
prop with support it's kind of a bump in
the road without support it can be
catastrophic
so i really think that that's an
important piece of this if you want to
go deep yes you need to put this support
group around you
absolutely first
because otherwise you'll just have to
keep slowing down
i didn't did mention i'm not that
patient
this is a critical part of the awakening
architectures
is having this both one on one
where there's a personalized
distillation
for exactly where the person's at as
well as the integrative
post trampolining you get these landing
zones
that sort of help
i would be curious to wrap with you on
one last subject which is
yikes yeah we've been already cruising
to make a text
because i'm late for my next appointment
okay
excellent they're already texting me
yeah we did cruise through our our time
slot
oh i see also i was in a session before
this
and tyson had messaged me i pass you
along my love
tyson super grateful for
all of your love and epic coordination
thank you
thank you the admin of the medical
yeah okay so
the question would be
when you experience
no self are you experiencing
everything as one
it all as life
depends on what practice you're doing if
you're doing a teravata oriented
practice you would you could call it a
profound flow state where nothing's
fixated so there's no
boundaries in any way it's just
vibratory energy
any of the sense gates that you turn to
it's just unfix that
unfixated vibratory energy so you don't
you don't make sound in anything you
don't make visual experience in anything
you can't detect
the inside or the outside of the body
you can't detect
one sensegate's edge in another sense
case it's all just that one
flowing vibratory energy space
and there are other sort of no-self
well i would say descriptions uh
in the if you're holding a big space
and everything is just an arising and in
passing of
energy events and the self arises and
passes there's no
identification at all with the
experience of self so you could describe
that as a no self experience
i tend to think of the no self
discussions though more toward the
theravada
place and uh it's described more in
tibetan practices as emptiness practice
yeah that's approximately what is
resonating for me right now and
is i would say the fundamental
last step
of the awakening is to abide as the very
inexhaustible source of infinite
creation and
just going beyond coming and going
shinzon used to say he wanted to know
what enlightened people did
when they weren't doing anything and so
he would sneak up
on sasaki roshi's house and peep in the
window
and he would just be sitting there
[Laughter]
yep so and that's what you could also
call holding space
just abiding in space
and the 2020s
will become even noisier and there will
become
even more demand for silence
for awakening for people that know how
to just hold space
well yeah
what's coming is going to be intense and
we're going to have to respond in a way
that's inclusive
or we're going to be at war
that's how i sort of see it
because it's one intelligence there's as
you
mentioned earlier where do you draw an
edge you can't even draw an edge with
your own inhalation of oxygen right now
let alone between you and the
very planet that secretes you and keeps
you alive
just become more and more relaxed into
the fact that it's one intelligence at
play with itself
and then create from that place and as
you do that
then the architectures will be
pro life and anti-war good
yeah great okay let's wrap
all right that was super
thank you george that was super all
right loved it thanks michael we really
appreciate you too thank you for
making the introduction happen and for
making the show happen that was a blast
thanks everyone for tuning in infinite
adoration
we would love to hear your thoughts in
the comments below on the episode let us
know
what you think like the video if you
brought your value helps the algorithm
subscribe if you have into the channel
share the video with people that you
feel like this would profoundly
influence
check out our
good old friends at the meta group the
link is in the biobelowmetagroup.org
check it out and
a lot of great classes and retreats are
available
up there so go ahead and give that a
check out yeah
and that is
all thank you much love
bye